E aí
oi oi gente
mundo tem medo de alguma coisa
ah e hoje eu vim aqui compartilhar um
pouquinho com vocês um dos grandes medos
menos que eu penso o mesmo de muitas
vezes errar o medo de errar o medo de
ser cancelado para usar o temos que são
mais modernos vamos chamar assim tudo
isso porque de alguma forma eu fui
criado para ser um vencedor para tirar
10 o tempo inteiro para ser o melhor pai
o melhor marido o melhor aluno o melhor
estudo eu fizesse a todo momento da
minha vida e é hoje aqui olhando para
vocês e sendo incentivado o tempo
inteiro a ser bem sucedido a vencer o
jogo a fazer o bem a ganhar curtida e
compartilhamento as influenciadores e de
fato eu cansei e aqui
expondo as minhas feridas em um dos
maiores palcos do mundo e começa para
mim um processo de respiração
e o invés de ser preparado para essas
camadas vitórias da vida na verdade o
que eu gostaria mesmo é de ser preparado
para todas as derrotas para todas as
perdas
produtos para o erro a não aceitação
para enfrentar essa própria cultura do
cancelamento
e como pesquisador Eu frequentei por um
ano uma escola de ensino médio
o conjunto todos os dias com os alunos
da vida está em sete horas da manhã até
as 5 horas da tarde e lá eu teve alguns
dados qualitativos que me saltaram muito
aos olhos e eu queria compartilhar com
vocês aqui hoje
é o primeiro deles é que os jovens não
sabem lidar com frustração
e não foi uma nem duas nem três vezes eu
vi jovem chorando nos cantos nos
corredores símbolos banheiros e tinha
muito dificuldade de lidar com seus
problemas com as perdas com as suas
dores as suas frustrações quando via uma
menina chorando no canto é
desesperadamente por ter perdido o
namorado que ele chora não era só de ter
perdido o acabado um relacionamento
que eles for parecia ser de algum e
perdeu o amor da vida dela para sempre
é algo muito uma linguagem muito perboli
é tenso isso intenso
o outro dado importante que eu o
observei lá os jovens não conhecem a rua
e a grades as grades dos condomínios da
própria escola os muros dos shoppings e
dos lugares que eles frequentam muitas
vezes sugerem conforme sugerem segurança
para aquela lógica do útero materno
aquela sensação que você tem ali no
útero de está sendo protegido alimentado
de ficar confortável ali o tempo todo
literalmente uma zona de conforto
é mas a verdade é que tantos jovens como
cada um de nós quando sai desse útero
materno
e começa a tentar reproduzir a mesma
sensação por todos os lugares onde passa
é com fortes é a segurança e aí ele não
vai para rua e aí nós não vamos para rua
porque achamos que o nosso mundo é o
mundo inteiro mas na verdade sem
conhecer a rua não dá para conhecer um
e no terceiro dados eles não tem
liberdade para testar
há 17 anos ele já tem que escolher o
vestibular a profissão que eles vão
seguir minha vida toda eles são tempo
inteiro incentivadas
pelos pais pelos professores pelos
colegas pela sociedade por eles mesmos a
escolher aquilo que pode ser sempre a
grande eu diria Até que até dez anos
atrás a gente teria cinco seis sete
profissões para escolher o ar disse um
jovem do ensino médio como 17 anos
escolhe sem Engenheiro ele vai ter mais
de 30 engenharia para escolher se ele
resolve o seu médico ele vai ter mais de
50 especialidades médicas para escolher
a cada vez mais difícil é o paradoxo da
Escolha eles não tem liberdade para
testar e não conseguem fazer da vida um
laboratório
Oi e a grande verdade vocês sabem é de
sem fazer experiência a gente não pode
dizer faz sentido ou não a gente precisa
de fato diferenciar simples
é mas agora tá aqui vindo dado mais
alarmante de todos vocês assim como
esses jovens Eu também não sei lidar com
frustrações Eu também mal conheço a rua
eu também não tenho muita liberdade para
testar
Olha para o meu filho de seis anos e
vejo que ele também não conhece direito
à rua está tão trancado no condomínio
ele não sabe lidar com as frustrações
dele e ele também
muitas vezes tem pouca liberdade para
testar
e talvez você que está aí me ouvindo
agora também não consiga lidar com suas
próprias frustrações e dores talvez você
não conhece a rua como imagina que
conhece e talvez você também não tem a
liberdade para testar e sabe por quê
Porque a gente nunca foi educado para
ele a gente não foi educado as pedras
mas para comprar histórias de sucesso e
perseguir incansavelmente aquilo que nos
falta grana curtida família feliz
emprego dos sonhos
óleo
imaginando vocês daqui também deve
Cansado de tudo isso de tanto texto
tanto discurso tanto esforço tantas
reuniões para chegar no fim do dia e
muitas vezes nem sequer dormir porque tá
ansioso pelo que falta bom e na
sociedade do que falta a gente acaba
esquecendo
aquilo que somos aquilo que temos e é
por isso que a minha proposição aqui
para vocês aqui diante de tantos
excessos a gente vive nesse momento no
mundo a gente Boost O que é o escasso
aquela coisa bem juvenil de fazer o
contrário só para zoar diante de tanta
rede social escolher aquela rede gostosa
tá dormir diante de tanto programa de
culinária
escolher fazer aquela comida que você
gosta para quem você ama Diante de tanta
falta de tempo encontrar um tempo só
para você
e nesse tempo só meu eu queria dizer que
eu quero muito ensinar e aprender a arte
da Regeneração da educação
regenerativa e fund de factos conceitos
e virar um pouco os valores para ver se
a gente lida melhor O que é erro
problema de Rota dá um respiro de
escasso diante de tantos excessos Talvez
uma fugidinha para ver como da rua está
alguma coisa nova
Oi e aí que vem uma grande descoberta da
minha vida que passa muito pelo símbolo
por esse símbolo que vocês vêm aqui na
minha camiseta que o Slash não entende
ao longo do tempo que essa barra mudou a
minha vida essa essa meu modo de pensar
ao conhecer uma pesquisa antropológica
de alguém que de fato foi para Rua nas
favelas cariocas e entendeu que a gente
não é mais uma única pessoa a gente não
é mais de um único jeito a gente não é
mais um devido a gente é um monte vivido
ou seja dentro de um Fábio existem
vários sábios e tudo bem se ele acorda
de um jeito e dorme de outro Isso faz
parte ao invés do ombro a gente escolhe
o Lê e a gente vai colocando um Slash
uma barra a cada com ele então hoje aqui
eu não estou só como educador
pesquisador palestrante mas eu participo
com o pai/cineasta/músico/
o
motivo/cervejeiro/enxadrista/introvertido/filósofo
muitas vezes frustrados aqui para de
alguma forma oferecer esses lanches para
vocês porque aquilo que eu sou e o que
eu sou passa também os meus slashes de
derrotas ou seja quero propor para vocês
começar a pensar na vida dentro da arte
da educação regenerativa a partir de
outras categorias não aquelas categorias
ainda que a gente foi educado o tempo
inteiro a vida inteira por exemplo
simples distinguir mal e bem certo
errado verdadeiro de falso a gente foi
criado por uma moral instituída e por
uma cultura que abrigou a muito nisso e
a gente ti hoje diante de tanta mudança
que estamos vivendo Talvez seja um exato
momentos e começarmos a pensar em outras
e
ao invés de mal Quem sabe a gente
poderia usar a palavra pesado né o
ideias de bem usar a palavra leve
e é ao invés de certeza a gente poderia
usar interessante a gente poderia usar
talvez
vocês sabem o quanto a palavra talvez ou
a palavra eu não sei podem fazer muita
diferença
na nossa vida pensar sobre novas
categorias ao invés de ficar pensando
sempre Vitória Vitória na palavra
vitória você pensar isso me emociona
Isso me arrepia
ao invés de derrota no seu usar Não dá
nada ou de dar errado você usar nosso de
cágados
é isso muda parece simples mas as
palavras fazem muita diferença eu quero
fazer com vocês um exercício
regenerativo da minha vida real tá é
ensino fundamental eu participei de uma
expectativa para o campeonato de futebol
Regional e nessas ele tiver 11 11 11
jogadores participando era um deles
esses 11 descem para o campeonato e um
só e essa cortada e vocês acham que foi
cortado
e eu passei um ano frustrado com vontade
de parar de jogar mas se eu fosse
educado de forma regenerativa talvez eu
tivesse parado naquele momento e dito
para mim mesmo não é nada daqui a pouco
tem outras seletivas eu posso me dedicar
a outra coisa
e há mais de dois meses eu perdi meu pai
por um câncer relâmpago eu desabei
pedindo a referência Foi algo que me fez
muito mal mas eu tenho muito grande esse
tempo usar categoria está sendo pesado
mas é suportável Porque eu sei que é
isso que ele me diria eu perdi que tem
eu achava perdi perdi tem uma chave que
era meu bem de amor que era certamente o
amor da minha vida
e eu parei de ter dito antes disso
Talvez seja o amor da minha vida isso
também muda perspectivo na sequência
fiquei inconformado troquei por outro
amor só para zoar foi uma piada e até
hoje eu tô tentando lidar com isso
também enfrentando sobre novas
categorias
e já aconteceu de uma fase da minha vida
muito perder inclusive de mim com
ansiedade crônica me perdi o reconhecido
pesado e talvez tenha me feito eu
descobri muitas coisas interessantes que
eu não sabia sobre mim mesmo e quer
saber a minha frustração mais recente
sempre foi meu sonho estar no palco do
prédio pisando nesse tapetinho vermelho
é olhando no rosto presencialmente cada
uma das pessoas ele foi que aconteceu
ontem eu fui fazer o teste
da a corrigir 19 de poder participar do
evento teste PCR eu fui positivado com
cozinha e por isso eu tô aqui falando
virtualmente com vocês e por isso faz
tanto sentido ele falando que agora tudo
que eu tô dizendo eu tô agora dizendo
para mim que não há nada que é só mais
um espinho que a gente tem é a mania de
que ele conseguir todas as coisas todas
juntas todas de uma vez só e é um certo
egoísmo achar que o mundo inteiro vai
estar sincronizado por oferecer um tempo
todo para Gente o que a gente quer
melhor pensar que a gente pode sim ter
poder essas coisas mas não todas as
coisas tudo junto junto ao mesmo tempo
aqui agora mas por Paiva
respeitando o nosso caminho
e agora esse simples é para simplória
perguntar sobre essas categorias que eu
tô falando Mas acredite faz muita
diferença quando a gente começa a dizer
para a gente mesmo que tá tudo bem se
não tá tudo bem porque assim mesmo
Slash e segue eu coloco uma barra me o
Passos o próximo o que que a gente tem
tanto medo de perder de frustrado dar
errado de ser cancelado a gente precisa
de inverter essas lojas
buscar de fato é site da Regeneração Eu
gosto muito de uma história de uma tribo
Africana e quando alguma pessoa comete
algum erro na tribo ela passa dois dias
no centro de uma roda com todas as
pessoas vão em torno dela é dizendo para
ela a palavra salvar Bona que quer dizer
eu reconheço você e dizendo para as
pessoas tudo de bom que ela já fez para
comunidade isso é o Whindersson o
Zoológico e ao mesmo tempo a pessoa olha
e diz escova que quer dizer eu esqueci
eu estou sendo reconhecidos você fez uma
cagada Mas vamos lá não dá nada a gente
pode recomeçar isso é Regeneração meu
filho também passa por uma fase de não
conseguir lidar com isso de erro erro
erro no seu tempo fazer é colocar ele no
centro e fica repetindo sempre o mesmo
mantra não tem problema e ra não tem
problema errar e Esse mantra pode ser o
mesmo que vocês podem repetir para vocês
mesmos todos os dias que consigam de
fato perceber as mudanças que vão
acontecendo ao longo da vida e quando
disserem que você podia ter dado um Xuxa
mais aquela seletivo você poderia pedir
para o mais vezes eu te amo para não
perder o amor é porque tá mais atento
para não ser assaltado você poderia ter
incentivado os seus pais a Capes anuais
e CNC
wi-fi sem problemas a gente pode ser
tudo mas não tudo ao mesmo tempo e agora
a gente precisa respeitar abafar e eu
digo aqui para vocês o dia eu perder a
última coisa que me resta vida eu quero
que as pessoas lembrem do perdedor
interessante que eu fui muitas vezes
frustrado dos slashers que eu deixei e
do desejo de educação as pessoas para as
peles
e como lidar com nossas frustrações
pensando sobre novas categorias em
Campos escasso só para zoar vamos dizer
não dá nada Vamos fazer esperança de ir
para rua no sentido de agir com uma
perna que sensibilidade não de
julgamentos admirando o sabonete assim
interessante vamos ser Slash aprender
colocar Barras testar testar está perto
e fique mais leve um dia meu pai perdeu
tudo que tinha no negócio que parecia
ser super para emissoras AM e quando eu
tava voltando para ele com ele dentro do
carro eu disse pai e agora o que a gente
vai fazer a gente já perdeu tudo que
tinha que a gente vai comer amanhã
e Ele olhou para mim e disse que uma
leveza muito grande no olhar que eu me
lembro até hoje agora nós vamos começar
de novo
bom e foi ali que nos regeneramos em
tempo de cancelamento vamos disseminar o
começar de novo todos os dias a uma
oportunidade para começar de novo
esperando nós coisa de cada vez não
todos esse alguns algumas pessoas
cancelaram esse meu momento de
frustração e glória tudo bem
slechts één van